et encore moins une maison de classe moyenne où les mettre.
La pièce devait demeurer parfaite.
Mais chaque jour, je risquais d'y mettre du désordre
simplement pour voir ce livre.
Sur la couverture, une femme du nom de Septima Clark était assise.
Elle était assise parfaitement de profil, son visage levé vers le ciel,
ses tresses poivre et sel parfaites
plaquées sur les côtés de la tête ;
la fierté et la sagesse émanaient de sa peau mate.
Septima Clark était une activiste et une éducatrice,
un modèle selon lequel j'allais façonner ma propre carrière.
Mais au-delà de tous les mots qu'elle a prononcés,
ce seul portrait de Septima Clark
a défini ma notion de confiance en moi
avant même que je ne connaisse le mot.
Cela peut sembler simple,
mais nous sous-estimons l'importance de la confiance en soi.
Nous la traitons comme une chose utile plutôt que nécessaire.
Nous attribuons plus de valeur aux connaissances et aux ressources
qu'à ce que nous considérons être le savoir-être de la confiance ne soi.
Mais à presque tous les égards, nous avons plus de savoir
et de ressources actuellement que n'importe quand durant l'histoire
et l'injustice foisonne et les défis persistent.
Si le savoir et les ressources étaient ce dont nous avions besoin,
nous n'en serions plus là.
La confiance en soi est l'une des principales choses
qui manquent dans l'équation.
Je suis obsédée par la confiance ne soi.
Cela a été le périple le plus important de ma vie,
un périple que je suis encore en train d'effectuer.
La confiance en soi est l'étincelle nécessaire avant tout ce qui suit.
La confiance en soi est la différence entre le fait d'être inspiré
et le fait de commencer,
entre le fait d'essayer et de faire jusqu'à ce que ce soit fait.
La confiance en nous nous aide à avancer même quand nous échouons.
Le nom du livre sur la table basse était : « Je rêve d'un monde »
et aujourd'hui je rêve d'un monde où une confiance en nous révolutionnaire
nous aide à réaliser nos rêves les plus ambitieux.
C'est exactement le genre de monde que je voulais créer dans ma classe
quand j'étais enseignante,
comme un monde de pure imagination à la Willy Wonka,
mais scolaire.
Tous mes élèves étaient noirs ou métis.
Ils grandissaient tous dans un milieu à faibles revenus.
Certains étaient des immigrants, certains étaient handicapés,
mais ils étaient tous les dernières personnes
que ce monde invite à avoir confiance en elles.
C'est pourquoi il était si important que ma classe soit un lieu
où mes élèves puissent développer le muscle de leur confiance en eux,
où ils puissent apprendre à faire face à chaque jour
avec la confiance en eux nécessaire
à repenser le monde à l'image de leurs rêves.
Après tout, que sont les compétences académiques
sans la confiance en soi pour employer ces compétences
pour changer le monde ?
Je devrais maintenant vous parler de deux de mes élèves, Jamal et Regina.
J'ai changé leurs noms, mais leurs histoires restent les mêmes.
Jamal était brillant, mais n'arrivait pas à se concentrer.
Il se tortillait dans sa chaise quand il travaillait seul
et il ne tenait jamais en place plus de trois ou quatre minutes.
Les élèves comme Jamal peuvent troubler les nouveaux enseignants
car ils ne savent pas bien comment accompagner les jeunes comme lui.
J'ai adopté une approche directe.
Je négociais avec Jamal.
S'il me donnait du travail concentré,
alors il pouvait le réaliser de n'importe où,
de sur le tapis de la classe à derrière mon bureau
en passant par l'intérieur de son casier, qui s'est avéré être son endroit favori.
La matière que Jamal aimait le moins était la rédaction
et il ne voulait jamais lire à voix haute ce qu'il avait rédigé,
mais nous réalisions des progrès.
Un jour, j'ai décidé d'organiser une simulation des élections de 2008
dans ma salle de classe.
Mes CE2 devaient faire des recherches et écrire un discours
pour le candidat de leur choix :
Barack Obama, Hillary Clinton ou John McCain.
Il était évident qui étaient les favoris,
mais un élève a choisi John McCain.
C'était Jamal.
Jamal a enfin décidé de lire à voix haute quelque chose qu'il avait rédigé
et, bien sûr, Jamal nous a tous éblouis par son brio.
Tout comme le père de Jamal, John McCain était un ancien combattant,
et, comme le père de Jamal le protégeait,
Jamal croyait que John McCain protégerait le pays tout entier.
Ce n'était pas mon candidat favori, mais cela n'importait pas
car toute la classe a éclaté en un tonnerre d'applaudissements,
une ovation pour notre courageux ami Jamal
qui s'était enfin présenté sous son jour le plus sûr de lui
pour la première fois cette année-là.
Puis il y a eu Regina.
Regina était tout aussi brillante, mais active.
Elle finissait inévitablement son travail en avance
puis elle s'attelait à distraire les autres élèves.
(Rires)
Marcher, parler,
passer ces mots haïs des enseignants, adorés des élèves.
Il semble que vous en ayez passés beaucoup.
(Rires)
Malgré mes grands idéaux pour notre classe,
j'en revenais trop souvent à mes instincts basiques
et je choisissais la conformité plutôt que la confiance en soi.
Regina était un accroc dans le système que j'avais conçu.
Un bon enseignant peut corriger un écart de conduite
mais demeurer un allié de l'élève.
Mais un jour en particulier,
j'ai simplement choisi le contrôle.
J'ai craqué
et mon approche n'a pas communiqué à Regina
que ses actions étaient une distraction.
Mon approche a communiqué à Regina qu'elle était une distraction.
J'ai regardé la lueur s'éteindre dans ses yeux
et cette lueur créait de la joie dans notre classe.
Je venais de l'étouffer.
Toute la classe est devenue irritable
et nous ne nous en sommes pas remis de toute la journée.
Je pense souvent à ce jour-là
et j'ai prié pour ne pas avoir causé de tort irréparable,
car en tant que femme qui fut une petite fille tout comme Regina,
je sais que j'aurais pu entamer le processus d'éradication
de sa confiance en elle à jamais.
Un manque de confiance en nous nous tire vers le bas
et nous accable,
nous écrasant dans un déluge
de « je ne peux pas », « je ne le ferai pas » et « impossible ».
Sans confiance en nous, nous nous trouvons coincés
et quand nous sommes coincés, nous ne pouvons même pas démarrer.
Au lieu de nous engluer dans de possibles obstacles,
la confiance en nous nous invite à agir avec certitude.
Nous opérons tous différemment quand nous savons pouvoir gagner
que lorsque nous ne faisons qu'espérer le pouvoir.
Ce pourrait être un contrôle utile.
Si vous n'avez pas assez confiance en vous,
ce pourrait être car vous devez ajuster votre objectif.
Si vous avez trop confiance en vous,
vous n'êtes peut-être pas ancré dans le réel.
Tout le monde ne manque pas de confiance en soi.
Dans cette société, nous rendons cela plus simple
pour certains de prendre en confiance en eux
car ils correspondent à l'archétype du leadership que nous préférons.
Nous récompensons la confiance en soi chez certains
et la punissons chez d'autres.
Et pendant ce temps, bien trop de gens
se promènent chaque jour sans confiance en eux.
Pour certains d'entre nous,
la confiance en nous est un choix révolutionnaire
et ce serait notre plus grande honte
de voir nos meilleures idées ne pas se réaliser
et nos rêves les plus brillants ne pas être atteints
simplement car nous manquions du moteur qu'est la confiance en nous.
Ce n'est pas un risque que je suis prête à prendre.
Quelle est la solution pour la confiance en soi ?
D'après mes estimations, il faut au moins trois choses :
la permission, une communauté et de la curiosité.
La permission donne naissance à la confiance en soi,
la communauté la nourrit
et la curiosité l'affirme.
Dans l'éducation, nous avons un dicton :
vous ne pouvez pas être ce que vous ne pouvez pas voir.
Petite, je ne pouvais pas faire preuve de confiance en moi
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un me montre comment.
Dans ma famille, nous faisions tout ensemble,
y compris des choses banales comme acheter une voiture
et, à chaque fois,
j'observais mes parents se donner en spectacle.
Nous entrions dans la concession,
mon père s'asseyait
pendant que ma mère faisait son tour.
Quand ma mère avait trouvé une voiture qu'elle aimait,
ils allaient à la rencontre du concessionnaire
et, inévitablement, à chaque fois, le concessionnaire dirigeait son attention
et tournait son corps vers mon père,
supposant que c'était lui qui gérait le porte-monnaie
et de fait cette négociation.
« Révérend Packnett, disait-il,
comment pouvons-nous vous faire acheter cette voiture ? »
Mon père répondait inévitablement de la même manière.
Lentement et silencieusement,
il faisait un geste en direction de ma mère
puis remettait ses mains sur ses genoux.
C'était peut-être la stupéfaction
de négocier des finances avec une femme noire dans les années 80,
mais quoi que ce fût,
j'observais ma mère travailler ces concessionnaires
jusqu'à ce qu'ils en soient à donner gratuitement la voiture.
(Rires)
Elle ne souriait jamais.
Elle n'avait jamais peur de s'en aller.
Je sais que ma mère pensait obtenir une bonne affaire pour un monospace,
mais ce qu'elle faisait vraiment,
c'était me donner la permission de défier les attentes
et d'avoir confiance en mes aptitudes, peu importe qui doutait de moi.
La confiance en soi permet à la permission d'exister
et la communauté est l'endroit le plus sûr pour essayer sa confiance en soi.
Je suis allée au Kenya pour en apprendre plus sur l'habilitation des femmes
chez les femmes Masaï.
J'y ai rencontré un groupe de jeunes femmes,
l'équipe des lionnes,
faisant partie des premiers groupes de gardes communautaires féminins.
Ces huit jeunes femmes courageuses écrivaient l'histoire
durant leurs années adolescentes
et j'ai demandé à Purity, la jeune garde la plus loquace d'entre elles :
« T'arrive-t-il d'avoir peur ? »
Je vous promets que j'aimerais me faire tatouer sa réponse sur le corps.
Elle a dit : « Bien sûr,
mais je fais appel à mes sœurs.
Elles me rappellent que nous serons meilleures que ces hommes
et que nous n'échouerons pas. »
La confiance en elle que Purity a
pour chasser les lions et attraper les braconniers
ne vient pas seulement de son aptitude physique ou de sa foi.
Sa confiance en elle a été renforcée par la sororité,
par la communauté.
Ce qu'elle disait, c'est que si j'ai des doutes,
j'ai besoin que vous soyez là
pour restaurer mon espoir
et rétablir ma certitude.
Dans la communauté, je peux trouver ma confiance en moi
et votre curiosité peut l'affirmer.
Tôt durant ma carrière, j'ai mené un gros événement
qui ne s'est pas déroulé exactement comme prévu.
Je vous mens. C'était terrible.
Quand j'ai débriefé l'événement avec ma responsable,
je savais qu'elle allait parcourir la liste
de toutes les erreurs que j'avais commises,
probablement depuis ma naissance.
Au lieu de cela, elle a ouvert avec une question :
« Quelle était ton intention ? »
J'étais surprise mais soulagée.
Elle savait que je m'en voulais déjà
et cette question m'a invitée à apprendre de mes erreurs
au lieu de porter atteinte à ma confiance en moi déjà fragile.
La curiosité invite les gens à être en charge de leur apprentissage.
Cet échange m'a aidée à approcher le projet suivant
avec des attentes de réussite.
La permission, une communauté, de la curiosité :
ce sont les choses dont nous aurons besoin pour engendrer la confiance en nous
dont nous aurons besoin pour résoudre nos plus grands défis
et pour bâtir le monde dont nous rêvons,
un monde où l'on met un terme à l'inégalité et où la justice existe,
un monde où nous pouvons être libres à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
car nous savons qu'aucun d'entre nous n'est libre
tant que nous ne le sommes pas tous.
Un monde qui n'est pas intimidé par la confiance en soi
quand elle se manifeste sous la forme d'une femme,
de peau noire
ou quelconque forme différente de nos archétypes favoris de leadership.
Un monde qui sait que ce genre de confiance en soi
est exactement la clé qu'il nous faut pour libérer le futur que nous voulons.
J'ai assez de confiance en moi pour croire que ce monde
arrivera un jour
et que nous serons ceux qui le feront advenir.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)